OK, here's a question that I wasn't sure if it was appropriate to ask a priest. But I had a priest in the studio, and I asked the question. And the priest, Father Tom Santa from St. Michael's Church in Old Town in Chicago, was kind enough to humor me. My question was, in confession, do people ever confess things to you that it's hard not to roll your eyes at?
好的，这是一个我不太确定是否适合问神父的问题。但我当时工作室里正好有一位神父，我就问了。这位神父是来自芝加哥老城圣迈克尔教堂的汤姆·圣塔神父，他很友好地满足了我的好奇心。我的问题是，在告解时，有没有人向你告解一些让你很难不翻白眼的事情？
[LAUGHS] In front of them, no. But yes. I had one person-- and I won't tell you what city, because he might be listening-- who would come in and every single confession would confess that he laughed in church. And I asked him, why do you laugh in church? He said, because Father tells jokes.
[笑] 在他们面前，不会。但确实有。我遇到过一个人——我不会告诉你他在哪个城市，因为他可能正在听——他每次来告解，告解的内容都是他在教堂里笑了。我问他，你为什么要在教堂里笑？他说，因为神父讲了笑话。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And I said, Father wants you to laugh in church. Well, you're not allowed to laugh in church. If you're not allowed to laugh in church, then Father wouldn't be telling you jokes. I know. That's his problem, not mine. [LAUGHS]
我说，神父是希望你在教堂里笑的。嗯，教堂里是不准笑的。如果教堂里不准笑，那神父就不会给你讲笑话了。我知道。那是他的问题，不是我的。[笑]
Well, today we have a whole program about confessions. We have a story about somebody who does confess and a story about somebody who refuses to confess. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , by the way, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
那么，今天我们的整个节目都关于“告解”。我们有一个关于某人确实告解的故事，还有一个关于某人拒绝告解的故事。这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目，顺便说一下，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
And we called Father Santa to start the show because Father Santa is an expert in something called scrupulosity, which takes a number of different kinds of forms. But among Catholics, it results in people confessing to things they do not need to confess.
我们请圣塔神父来开启这个节目，因为圣塔神父是一位研究“拘泥症”的专家，这种病症有多种表现形式。但在天主教徒中，它表现为人们会去告解一些根本不需要告解的事情。
Scrupulosity is when somebody obsesses over whether he is doing things that are sinful. It causes anxiety. The person can't stop thinking about it. It's something that the Catholic church has been noting and dealing with for hundreds of years. A number of saints suffered from this.
拘泥症是指一个人过度沉迷于自己是否在做罪恶之事。这会导致焦虑。当事人无法停止思考这件事。这是天主教会几百年来一直注意并处理的问题。许多圣徒也曾饱受其苦。
Father Santa says that it can be paralyzing for people. It can make the smallest decisions impossible. He remembers one woman that he spoke to when he was just starting out as a priest.
圣塔神父说，这会让人们感到瘫痪。它会让最小的决定都变得不可能。他记得他刚做神父时，曾与一位女士交谈。
She called the rectory. I answered the phone, and she identified who she was. And she says, Father, I'm trying to decide if I should make tomato soup or chicken noodle soup for my husband for dinner. Which one is not a sin?
她给牧师住宅打了电话。我接了电话，她自报了家门。她说，神父，我正在试图决定今晚该给丈夫做番茄汤还是鸡汤面。哪一种才不算犯罪？
It's because she felt that if she prepared the wrong soup, she would disappoint her husband or her children or her guest. And that's what's displeasing to God.
这是因为她觉得如果她做了错误的汤，她就会让丈夫、孩子或客人失望。而那正是让上帝不悦的事。
Because God would be displeased if her family were upset.
因为如果她的家人感到不开心，上帝会不高兴。
That's right. Right. Yeah. There must, therefore, be a sin.
没错。对。是的。因此，那一定是一种罪。
How did you respond?
你是怎么回应的？
I responded by I think I told her to pick the tomato soup. [LAUGHS]. I just made the decision.
我回应时……我想我告诉她选番茄汤。[笑]。我就直接做了决定。
And I was young. I was newly ordained. I didn't realize anything. I didn't realize anything more than that she seemingly was asking me a question.
那时我很年轻。我刚被任命。我什么都不懂。我除了意识到她似乎在问我一个问题之外，什么都没意识到。
It wasn't until later, when I was talking to other priests, that I realized that I had encountered my first scrupulous person and that my answer was, in fact, not very pastoral, but pretty flippant. So I've tried to outgrow being flippant.
直到后来，当我与其他神父交谈时，我才意识到我遇到了我的第一个拘泥症患者，而我的回答，事实上，一点也不牧灵，反而相当轻率。所以我努力改掉这种轻率。
It's funny. You're saying it's a bad answer. But at another level, it's a perfectly helpful and good answer, because it took her out of her pain.
很有趣。你说这是一个糟糕的回答。但在另一个层面上，这是一个非常有用且好的回答，因为它让她从痛苦中解脱出来了。
Until the next time she opened the cabinet, yes.
直到她下次打开橱柜的时候，是的。
Oh, good. You see, that's why you're a priest.
哦，好的。你看，这就是为什么你是神父。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Father  Santa has written a book for sufferers. He leads retreats. He edits a newsletter, which people send questions to. Like for instance, you're supposed to fast for an hour before taking Communion, which Father Santa says is pretty easy.
圣塔神父为受苦者写了一本书。他主持静修会。他编辑一份时事通讯，人们会给它寄去问题。例如，你应该在领圣体前禁食一小时，圣塔神父说这其实很简单。
Anybody who goes to church, it's about an hour before you receive communion. But anyways, if they  have scrupulosity, they'll be concerned that for instance, as they're sitting there in church, they discovered that they had a seed left in their mouth and they swallowed it. Does that break their fast? Or does lipstick break your fast? Or things like that.
任何去教堂的人，这大约是你领圣体前的一小时。但不管怎样，如果他们有拘泥症，他们会担心，比如，当他们坐在教堂里时，他们发现嘴里还留着一颗种子，然后把它吞下去了。这会打破他们的禁食吗？或者口红会打破你的禁食吗？或者诸如此类的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
Another one I get commonly is, we're going to go on a cruise and there's no guarantee that we'll have Sunday Mass. So am I committing a mortal sin by skipping Sunday Mass?
另一个我经常收到的问题是，我们要去游轮旅行，不能保证会有主日弥撒。那么我不参加主日弥撒是在犯大罪吗？
I said no, you're on a boat, and that's what you do. Enjoy your trip. Have a great time. Don't worry about it.
我说没有，你在船上，这就是你该做的。享受你的旅程吧。玩得开心。不用担心这个。
Somebody wrote your newsletter, I sometimes get frustrated with my dog. Is this a serious sin?
有人写信给你的时事通讯问，我有时会对我的狗感到沮丧。这是严重的罪吗？
Right. See, and what that is is what they're really saying, it's not the dog. What they're really saying is, I felt an emotion. And is that emotion acceptable or unacceptable?
对。你看，他们真正想说的不是狗的事。他们真正想说的是，我产生了一种情绪。这种情绪是可以接受的还是不可接受的？
Somebody wrote your newsletter, is it a sin to exaggerate a little when telling a story to friends? I only mean to add a little color.
有人写信给你的时事通讯问，给朋友讲故事时稍微夸大一点是一种罪吗？我只是想增加一点色彩。
Right. It's called a skill.
对。这叫技巧。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
There's a lot of people who make lots of money with that ability.
有很多人靠这种能力赚了很多钱。
Father Santa says that there are two different kinds of scrupulosity. There are the people who are just not sure what is a sin and what is not a sin, and they're getting very stressed out about that. That is pretty straightforward to deal with, he says. A priest just needs to patiently talk these people through what counts as a sin. And usually over the course of months, the anxieties fade.
圣塔神父说，拘泥症有两种不同的类型。有些人只是不确定什么是罪，什么不是罪，他们为此感到非常紧张。他说，处理这种情况相当直接。神父只需要耐心地向这些人解释什么是罪。通常在几个月的时间里，焦虑就会消退。
Much more difficult are the people who have an actual psychological disorder, whose scrupulosity is tied up with what priests have come to understand in the last three or four decades is obsessive compulsive disorder. Like for instance, a man who felt that he could not get out of bed in the morning until he believed that he was doing it in a pure way that would not offend God. Or people who believe that they are constantly blaspheming God.
更难处理的是那些患有实际心理障碍的人，他们的拘泥症与神父在过去三四十年里开始理解的强迫症联系在一起。例如，一个男人觉得他在确信自己是以一种不会冒犯上帝的纯洁方式起床之前，都无法起床。或者那些认为自己不断在亵渎上帝的人。
Or a woman who thought that if she left her house unlocked, it would put her whole family in danger, which she believed was a sin. So she would check the lock over and over and over and over.
或者一个女人认为如果她不锁好门，就会让她的全家处于危险之中，她认为这是一种罪。所以她会一遍又一遍地检查门锁。
Father Santa says that in confession, these people describe their sins without feeling. They do it almost mechanically. They ask the same questions over and over, not accepting the answers that they're given. He calls this the scrupulous ritual. He says that the only thing that can help these people is therapy, behavior modification, drugs.
圣塔神父说，在告解时，这些人描述他们的罪时没有感情。他们几乎机械地这样做。他们反复问同样的问题，不接受给他们的回答。他称之为“拘泥仪式”。他说，唯一能帮助这些人的是治疗、行为矫正、药物。
And Father Santa says that unfortunately, these are not people who usually go for that. On a retreat with 20 people, he'll maybe be able to convince one or two of them to seek that kind of professional help. The ones who refuse sometimes tell him that he's just trying to let them off too easy for their sins.
圣塔神父说，不幸的是，这些人通常不去寻求这些帮助。在有20人的静修会上，他或许能说服其中一两个寻求那种专业帮助。那些拒绝的人有时告诉他，他只是想让他们因为自己的罪而逃避惩罚。
They are convinced that it is God's will for them that they suffer this way. Accept it as their personal cross. And somehow they have to live like this.
他们确信这是上帝的旨意，让他们这样受苦。接受它作为他们的个人十字架。他们不知何故必须这样生活。
Now, you have an example in your book about you got a letter in a box, and it was 150 pages. Is that what it was?
现在，你的书里有一个例子，你收到了一个盒子里装的信，有150页长。是这样的吗？
Yes it was. It was the most incredible--
是的，确实如此。这是最不可思议的——
And just explain what this was. Yeah.
解释一下这是什么。是的。
At the time, I was publisher of our publishing house, Liguori Publications in St. Louis. And I thought it was a manuscript that had appeared on my desk for publication, so I started reading it.
当时，我是圣路易斯利古里出版社的出版人。我以为那是一份出现在我办公桌上供出版的手稿，所以我开始阅读它。
And it was the most unbelievable 150 pages describing this person's struggle with sin, with sexuality, everything that you could possibly imagine. 150 pages in the most unbelievable amount of details, all summarized by chapters with questions that would go with it.
那是最令人难以置信的150页，描述了这个人与罪、与性、所有你能想象到的一切的斗争。150页的内容，有着令人难以置信的细节，所有内容都按章节总结，并附有与之相关的问题。
And the closing paragraph said, I have two questions for you. One, would you be willing to hear my confession? And the second one is, do you think I'm scrupulous?
结束语写道：我有两个问题想问你。第一，你愿意听我的告解吗？第二个是，你认为我有拘泥症吗？
Was it surprising to you that this person was even asking the question?
这个人在问这个问题，让你感到惊讶吗？
No. It wasn't surprising to me. What was surprising to me was the level of commitment, first of all, that was required in order to write that and the level of suffering that it expressed. Every page was filled with suffering. And that's what hit me more than anything else. And it certainly isn't God's will for us. There's no way that's God's will.
不。我并不感到惊讶。让我惊讶的是，首先，写下这些所需要的承诺水平，以及它所表达的痛苦程度。每一页都充满了痛苦。这就是比任何其他事情都更打动我的地方。这绝不是上帝对我们的旨意。这绝不可能是上帝的旨意。
Confession, Father Santa says, can be such  a satisfying part of a priest's job. To help somebody heal and cope and get closer to God, it's at the heart of why some people become priests in the first place. It can be very intense.
圣塔神父说，告解可以是神父工作中非常令人满足的一部分。帮助某人治愈、应对并更接近上帝，这是某些人成为神父的核心原因。这可能会非常强烈。
And I can't remember many weddings and baptisms clearly. But there are confessions over the years that I can remember very, very clearly as if they happened yesterday.
我记不清很多婚礼和洗礼了。但多年来，有些告解我记得非常非常清楚，就像昨天发生的一样。
Yeah.
是的。
It's also frustrating when you can't do it. When you just can't do it. There's no word that you can say that will bring healing. There's nothing that you can say that will bring people to a sense of peace. That's frustrating, because you want it so bad for them.
当你做不到的时候，也很沮丧。当你就是做不到的时候。没有任何话语可以说能带来治愈。没有任何话语可以说能给人们带来内心的平静。那很令人沮丧，因为你太想为他们做到了。
And that's what can be so hard with a scrupulous confession.
这就是拘泥症告解最困难的地方。
That's the hard part about it. Especially if you're sitting in the confessional and you've already been in the confessional for an hour, an hour and a half.
那是最难的部分。特别是如果你坐在告解室里，而你已经在告解室里待了一个小时、一个半小时了。
And you're extremely vulnerable when you're in the confessional. You never know what the person is that's going to come in, what they're going to talk about. You never know if it's something that's relatively unimportant or it's the deepest, darkest secret. You never know.
当你坐在告解室里时，你非常脆弱。你永远不知道进来的会是什么样的人，他们会谈论什么。你永远不知道这只是一件相对不重要的事情，还是最深沉、最黑暗的秘密。你永远不知道。
And it's very draining to give individual energy to each person that comes in, to listen to them with a patient, loving heart. And so after an hour and a half, for instance, and you end up with a scrupulous person that comes in, and all they're doing is engaging in this scrupulous ritual, that has got to be one of the most difficult things I've ever done as a priest, to sit there and be patient and loving. Because all I really want to do is just slam the door and forget it.
给进来的每个人提供个人的精力，用耐心、充满爱的心去倾听他们，这非常消耗体力。所以，例如一个半小时后，你最终遇到了一个拘泥症患者，而他们所做的只是沉浸在这种拘泥仪式中，这一定是我做神父以来做过的最困难的事情之一，坐在那里保持耐心和爱心。因为我真正想做的只是关上门，把它忘掉。
But you can't. You can't. You have to wait and be patient and give them the love that they really, really desire and need.
但你不能。你不能。你必须等待，保持耐心，给予他们真正、真正渴望和需要的爱。
These people really test you.
这些人确实在考验你。
Yes. Our own saint Alphonsus Liguori, who was scrupulous, said he exhausted the confessors in Naples, the city he was from. Because whenever they saw Alphonsus enter into the city, they would all run because he would exhaust them.
是的。我们自己的圣阿尔方索·利古里，他自己就有拘泥症，他说他让那不勒斯的告解神父们筋疲力尽，那是他所在的城市。因为每当他们看到阿尔方索进城时，他们都会逃跑，因为他会让他们筋疲力尽。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he even admitted that he would do that.
他甚至承认他会那样做。
Father Tom Santa. His book is Understanding Scrupulosity, Questions, Helps, and Encouragement. His newsletter you can find online is "Scrupulous Anonymous."
汤姆·圣塔神父。他的书是《理解拘泥症：问题、帮助与鼓励》。你可以在网上找到他的时事通讯“拘泥匿名者”。
Act One, "Kim Possible." So this is the story of a criminal investigation that hinges entirely on a confession. And I am not going to pretend that this goes well. The case falls apart for some really interesting reasons. Here's Saul Elbein with the story.
第一幕，“金·波西布尔”。这是一个完全取决于告解的刑事调查故事。我不会假装事情进展顺利。这个案件因为一些非常有趣的原因分崩离析了。这是索尔·埃尔本带来的故事。
OK, I'm going to walk you through the evidence of this case, see if you can tell where it goes wrong. Here's the crime.
好的，我将带你梳理这个案件的证据，看看你能不能看出哪里出了问题。这是犯罪经过。
It was 1994. A man was found dead by the Anacostia River in Washington, DC. He'd been tied up and savagely beaten. Someone had taken his wallet and used his credit card at a liquor store, a drug store, and a Chinese restaurant. Police also had a surveillance photo from an ATM that looked like this woman named Kim. From public documents, they saw that her handwriting matched the signatures on the credit card slips.
那是1994年。一名男子被发现死在华盛顿特区的安那考斯蒂亚河边。他被捆绑并遭受了野蛮殴打。有人拿走了他的钱包，并在一家酒类商店、一家药店和一家中餐馆使用了他的信用卡。警方还有一张来自ATM机的监控照片，看起来像这个叫金的女人。根据公开文件，他们看到她的笔迹与信用卡签购单上的签名相符。
Jim Trainum was the lead detective on this case. It was one of his first major homicide investigations. And when he started interrogating Kim, she just denied everything. She told him she didn't know the dead man. She'd never signed any credit card slips. So they sat there for hours going back and forth. Then early that afternoon, Kim started to crack.
吉姆·特雷纳姆是此案的首席侦探。这是他最早的重大凶杀案调查之一。当他开始审讯金时，她只是全盘否认。她告诉他她不认识那个死者。她从未签过任何信用卡签购单。于是他们坐在那里几个小时，来回拉锯。那天下午早些时候，金开始崩溃了。
She tells us that you're right, I signed the credit card slips. But I found the credit cards. And I didn't steal them. I found them and I went out and used them.
她告诉我们，你说得对，我签了信用卡签购单。但我捡到了信用卡。我没有偷它们。我捡到了，然后出去用了它们。
Bingo. She admitted she was involved somehow. Now Jim figured it was only a matter of time until she told him everything.
宾果。她承认她以某种方式参与了其中。现在吉姆认为，她告诉他一切只是时间问题。
Oh my god! Here we are. We're doing good. We got to this stage. So we decided at that point that we would take what we got and put that  on videotape.
哦天哪！我们在这了。我们做得很好。我们到了这一步。所以我们当时决定把我们得到的东西录在录像带上。
So Jim turned on a video recorder to catch Kim confessing about the credit cards.
于是吉姆打开了录像机，捕捉金关于信用卡的告解。
Is that your signature there?
那是你的签名吗？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
OK. Let's see if we can refresh your memory here.
好的。让我们帮你回忆一下。
In the video, Jim is showing her credit card receipts. And even though she admitted signing them, she's suspiciously vague about the actual items she bought. And that made Jim think she was hiding something or covering for someone. She was petite, 19 years old. Not the sort of person who could beat a man to death by herself.
在录像中，吉姆在给她看信用卡收据。尽管她承认签了名，但她对实际购买的物品含糊其辞，这很可疑。这让吉姆觉得她在隐瞒什么或者在为某人掩盖。她身材娇小，19岁。不是那种能独自把一个男人殴打致死的人。
Jim figured she must have had accomplices. So he pressed her for details. And finally they got to a credit card charge made at the Chinese restaurant. He asked about her order, and she told them, I don't eat that much seafood, but I did have some shrimp.
吉姆认为她肯定有同伙。于是他逼问细节。最后他们谈到了在中餐馆的一笔信用卡消费。他问起她的订单，她告诉他们，我不怎么吃海鲜，但我确实吃了一些虾。
I don't eat that much seafood, but I did have some shrimp.
我不怎么吃海鲜，但我确实吃了一些虾。
There was a shrimp dish within the Chinese food. And so at the time, I am right there watching it through two-way glass. And when she says a shrimp dish, I'm jumping up and down. Because how would she know about the shrimp dish?
中餐里确实有一道虾类菜肴。当时我就在那里，透过双向玻璃看着。当她说出虾类菜肴时，我兴奋得跳了起来。因为她怎么会知道虾类菜肴的事？
Over the next several hours, she gave other details. The names of other stores that the credit card was used at. People's Drugstore, Golden Star Restaurant and Chat's Liquor. She knew what streets they were on and how much was spent there.
在接下来的几个小时里，她提供了其他细节。信用卡被使用的其他商店的名称。人民药店、金星餐厅和查特酒类商店。她知道它们在什么街道上，以及在那里花了多少钱。
Eventually, Kim also admitted to knowing the dead man. She told them that he had been sexually harassing her and she'd wanted him to stop. And then at about one o'clock in the morning, 17 hours into the interrogation, she caved. Spilled the whole thing.
最终，金也承认认识死者。她告诉他们，他一直在对她进行性骚扰，她想让他停止。然后在凌晨一点左右，审讯进行了17个小时后，她崩溃了。和盘托出了一切。
Kim said she and two friends waited for the man to get out of work and pulled him into their truck. They tried talking to him, but he wouldn't listen. He started to yell. So they decided to teach him a lesson.
金说她和两个朋友等着那个男人下班，把他拉进了他们的卡车。他们试图和他谈谈，但他不听。他开始大叫。所以他们决定给他一个教训。
On the confession tape, Kim fidgeted idly in her seat as she described beating him. She said, we started hitting him, punching him in the face at first. I got in a lick or two, probably more.
在告解录像带上，金在描述殴打他时，局促不安地坐在椅子上。她说，我们开始打他，先是打他的脸。我打了一两下，可能更多。
Starting hitting him, punching him in the face at first. I got a lick in or two. Probably more.
开始打他，先是打他的脸。我打了一两下。可能更多。
Kim said her friends kept hitting and punching him. She told them to stop, that it wasn't necessary, but they wouldn't listen. So she sat in the car and cried while they beat him to death.
金说她的朋友们一直在打他、揍他。她告诉他们停下来，说没必要，但他们不听。于是她坐在车里哭，而他们把他活活打死。
Started hitting him and hitting him and hitting him and punching him and kicking him. And I kept telling them, just stop. Just stop. It's not necessary. It's not really necessary.
开始打他，打他，打他，揍他，踢他。我一直告诉他们，停下。停下。没必要。真的没必要。
The damage was already done in the first place. So I just turned back in the truck   and just started crying.
起初损坏就已经造成了。所以我只是转过身，缩在卡车里开始哭泣。
In her confession, Kim came across as cold and unrepentant. At the end, one of the interrogators asked her if  she's sorry for what happened.
在她的告解中，金表现得冷漠且毫无悔意。最后，审讯人员问她是否对发生的事情感到抱歉。
I mean, are you sorry what happened to the guy?
我是说，你对那个家伙身上发生的事感到抱歉吗？
She said, yeah, I am. But he shouldn't have done what he did to me. He should have left me alone.
她说，是的，我感到抱歉。但他不应该对我做那样的事。他应该离我远点。
Yeah, I am. But he shouldn't have did what he did to me. He should have left me alone.
是的，我感到抱歉。但他不应该对我做那样的事。他应该离我远点。
The next day, Jim brought Kim to an arraignment hearing, where she was charged with felony murder and held without bond. So, great. Full confession. Perfect cop show ending. Roll credits.
第二天，吉姆带着金参加了传讯听证会，她在会上被控谋杀罪，不得保释。所以，太好了。完整的告解。完美的警匪片结尾。字幕滚动。
But then after a few months in jail, Kim recanted the whole thing. She said Jim and the other interrogators had told her what to say. Again, here's Jim.
但在监狱里待了几个月后，金推翻了一切。她说吉姆和其他审讯人员告诉她该说什么。再一次，这是吉姆。
She said, look, I don't want to cooperate anymore. I wasn't there. I had nothing to do with it.
她说，听着，我不想再配合了。我不在那儿。我与那事无关。
So we told her attorney, well look, if she's saying this, let her come in and have a full-blown polygraph test. And she did. She came in, she had a full-blown polygraph test, and she failed miserably.
于是我们告诉她的律师，好吧，听着，如果她这么说，让她进来接受一次完整的测谎测试。她做了。她进来了，她参加了一次完整的测谎测试，结果一败涂地。
Kim decided to cooperate again. But the cops felt they needed to strengthen their case against her, just in case she flaked on them again.
金决定再次配合。但警察觉得他们需要加强对她的案件，以防她再次反水。
And so what I needed to do was I needed to come up with possible things that we could show that she was out there that night. Anything whatsoever.
所以我需要做的是，我需要想出可能的证据来证明她那天晚上在那儿。任何东西都行。
And one of the things that we knew about was at the homeless shelter where she was living at the time, there was this log where you could sign and in sign out. And so I got a subpoena, went to the homeless shelter, and got the log.
我们知道的一件事是，在她当时居住的无家可归者收容所里，有一本记录本，你可以签入和签出。所以我申请了传票，去了收容所，拿到了那本记录。
And I was bringing it back to the office, and I flipped to the pages that had the entries for the night of the murder. And I looked down, and I about wrecked the car. She wasn't out during the critical times that we needed her out. And in fact, according to that book, there was no way that she could have participated in the murder.
我把它带回办公室，翻到谋杀案当晚的记录页。我往下看了一眼，差点把车撞了。她在我们需要的关键时刻并没有外出。事实上，根据那本书，她根本不可能参与谋杀。
And this is not like, OK, wait, stop?
这不像是，好的，等一下，停？
Yeah. We were trying to figure out, OK, well first off, it can't be her handwriting, right? Because she's confessed. We know that she was out. So this log cannot be right. Somebody else had to sign it.
是的。我们试图弄清楚，好吧，首先，那不可能是她的笔迹，对吧？因为她告解了。我们知道她出去了。所以这本记录肯定不对。肯定是别人签的。
By now, Kim had been in jail for a few months. Ideally, Jim should have checked the shelter's logs when they first picked her up. But Kim had confessed, so he didn't think it was necessary.
到这个时候，金已经在监狱里待了几个月了。理想情况下，吉姆应该在刚抓到她时就检查收容所的记录。但金已经告解了，所以他觉得没必要。
Jim, though, was getting uncomfortable. So he decided to recheck the basis of the case, the handwriting evidence. He went to a handwriting expert from the Secret Service to compare Kim's signature to the credit card slips.
然而，吉姆开始感到不安。所以他决定重新检查案件的基础，笔迹证据。他找了一位来自特勤局的笔迹专家，将金的签名与信用卡签购单进行比对。
They sat me down and they said, Jim, absolutely positively in no way did she sign these credit card slips. And I'm just going, holy! I feel bad, but I feel confused.
他们让我坐下，说，吉姆，绝对肯定，她绝对没有签这些信用卡签购单。我当时简直，天哪！我感到很糟糕，但我感到困惑。
And all, why would she have confessed? How did she know all these details? And yet how could our forensic ev-- the very foundation of our case, be so wrong?
而且，为什么她要告解呢？她怎么会知道所有这些细节？然而，我们的法医证据——我们案件的基石，怎么会错得这么离谱？
An expert trained by the FBI checked it out too and said nope, no way it was her. The handwriting expert Jim had first used had just gotten it wrong. So Jim took this new evidence back to the prosecutor.
一位受过联邦调查局训练的专家也检查过了，说不，绝对不可能是她。吉姆最初使用的笔迹专家只是搞错了。于是吉姆把这些新证据带回给检察官。
At this point, nine months had passed since her arrest and the court had to either indict Kim or let her go. Without any hard proof to take her to trial, the court dismissed Kim's case and she was released from jail. The police never found another suspect. The murder remains unsolved.
此时，距离她被捕已经过去了九个月，法院必须起诉金或释放她。由于没有任何有力证据将她送上法庭，法院驳回了金的案件，她被从监狱释放。警方从未找到其他嫌疑人。谋杀案至今未破。
Jim was still sure Kim had been involved somehow. Even if she hadn't signed the credit card slips, she confessed. She knew all these details that only someone who had been there would know.
吉姆仍然确信金以某种方式参与了其中。即使她没有签信用卡签购单，她也告解了。她知道所有这些只有身临其境的人才会知道的细节。
It wasn't just the stores and what was bought there. Kim knew how the dead man's hands had been tied up. She pointed out the ATM machine that his card had been used at. And then of course, she knew about the shrimp. Jim felt that she had just gotten away with murder.
这不仅仅是商店和在那里买了什么。金知道那个死者的手是怎么被捆绑的。她指出了他的卡被使用的ATM机。当然，她还知道虾的事。吉姆觉得她逍遥法外了。
I mean, I would play this through my mind over and over again, trying to figure out how she could have known these things without having been there or having been told these things by somebody who was.
我是说，我会在脑海中反复重演这件事，试图弄清楚她怎么能在没有在场的情况下，或者没有从在场的人那里得知这些事情的情况下知道这些东西。
So quick break here. Did you catch it, the humongous mistake that derailed Jim's entire investigation?
那么快速休息一下。你注意到了吗，导致吉姆整个调查脱轨的那个巨大错误？
Jim, for his part, had no idea. He knew he'd missed something, but he just could not figure out what. For years, he turned it over and over in his mind.
吉姆本人完全不知道。他知道他错过了一些东西，但他就是无法弄清楚是什么。多年来，他在脑海中反复回想。
And then around 2002, he got assigned to review cold cases for his department. And one of the cases he pulled? That murder by the Anacostia River.
然后大约在2002年，他被指派审查部门的悬案。他抽出的案件之一？就是安那考斯蒂亚河的那起谋杀案。
So Jim got the videotapes of Kim's confession. He thought maybe time and distance would reveal something in those tapes, something that would give him a reason to reopen the case.
于是吉姆拿到了金的告解录像带。他想也许时间和距离会在这些录像带中揭示一些东西，一些会让他有理由重启案件的东西。
I'm just sitting back with my feet up on the table. The TV's up there, the tape's running. And I just had an "oh, my god" moment. Oh my god, look! Look at what I've done!
我只是靠在椅子上，把脚放在桌子上。电视在上面，录像带在运行。然后我瞬间产生了一个“哦，天哪”的时刻。哦天哪，看！看看我做了什么！
What is this point?
这是什么意思？
Best my memory is the point where I'm telling her, let me refresh your memory.
凭我的记忆，这是我告诉她，“让我帮你回忆一下”的地方。
That your signature there?
那是你的签名吗？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
OK. Let's see if we can refresh your memory here.
好的。让我们帮你回忆一下。
At the exact moment when Jim heard "let me refresh your memory," he watched himself pushing copies of the credit card slips in front of Kim.
就在吉姆听到“让我帮你回忆一下”的准确时刻，他看着自己把信用卡签购单的复印件推到金的面前。
It was this sinking feeling. My heart's not stopping, but it's definitely not acting right.
那是一种下沉的感觉。我的心没有停止，但它肯定运作得不正常。
Watching the tape, he suddenly understood how she seemed to know so much.
看着录像带，他突然明白了她为什么似乎知道那么多。
She's looking at the credit card slips. She's sitting there staring at them. Think about what you can get off a credit card slip. You can get the name of the store, the location of the store. And it's like, how did we not see that?
她看着信用卡签购单。她坐在那里盯着它们。想想你能从信用卡签购单上得到什么。你能得到商店的名字、商店的位置。就像是，我们怎么会没看到呢？
It just started all to become so obvious to me. And the more I looked at it, the more instances I could pick up. And I realized fairly quickly that what we had here was a false confession, and that she was totally innocent.
这一切开始对我变得非常明显。我看的越多，能发现的例子就越多。我很快意识到我们这里有一个虚假告解，而且她是完全无辜的。
What are we working on right now? A murder, right?
我们现在在处理什么案子？谋杀，对吧？
No, a forgery.
不，伪造。
OK.
好的。
The lieutenant told me forgery.
中尉告诉我伪造。
All those details Jim had been fixated on all those years? He was the one  who gave them to her.
吉姆多年来一直盯着看的所有那些细节？他就是那个把它们喂给她的人。
Do you remember any of the items that you bought at People's?
你记得你在人民药店买了什么吗？
No.
不。
Like most of us, Jim had an image of the sort of cops who force false confessions. Bad apples. Cops who knowingly railroad some innocent to get the DA off their backs, or because they just don't care enough to do their jobs right.
像我们大多数人一样，吉姆对那种强迫虚假告解的警察有一种刻板印象。害群之马。那些故意冤枉无辜者以摆脱地区检察官的压力，或者因为他们根本不在乎是否做好工作的警察。
But now suddenly Jim realized he was a bad apple. And he wondered, how many other cases had he messed up? How many more confessions had he unknowingly coerced? Kim's interrogation was the only one he'd ever recorded.
但现在吉姆突然意识到他自己就是害群之马。他纳闷，他搞砸了多少其他案件？还有多少告解是他无意中强迫出来的？金的审讯是他唯一录下来的。
I just felt bad. I mean, I thought I was a very conscientious, very methodical, very detail-oriented detective. And I would never, ever want to feed information or contaminate a suspect. And here I am doing it plain as day.
我只是感觉很糟糕。我是说，我以为我是一个非常有良心、非常有条理、非常注重细节的侦探。我绝不想喂养信息或污染嫌疑人。而我却在这里明目张胆地这样做。
Over the years, Jim has watched these tapes dozens of times and has catalogued all the different ways that he and the other interrogators inadvertently led her into a false confession. At some point, Kim had heard, as she was facing 30 years in prison, how she might never get her kids back, and decided to give them what they wanted. So she stitched together the little pieces Jim and the other interrogators slipped her to make up a story they'd believe.
多年来，吉姆看了这些录像带几十次，并分类了所有他和审讯人员无意中引导她做出虚假告解的不同方式。在某个时刻，金在面临30年监禁的情况下，听说了她可能再也见不到孩子了，决定给他们想要的东西。所以她把吉姆和其他审讯人员递给她的零散碎片拼接起来，编成了一个他们会相信的故事。
Now when I say slipped, we're not talking about a little bit of information. We're talking about a lot. Kim's interrogation started around 8:00 AM and went until 1:00 AM the next day. And as the day wore on, the interrogators started to get tired and sloppy. Sometimes they just came out and told her actual details.
现在当我说“递给”时，我们谈论的不是一点点信息。我们谈论的是很多。金的审讯从早上8点左右一直持续到第二天凌晨1点。随着时间的推移，审讯人员开始感到疲倦和草率。有时他们只是直接出来告诉她实际的细节。
At one point, one of the interrogators got so frustrated trying to convince Kim that they knew what she did, that he told her. He said to her, we know what you ate. Kim responded, huh? What did I eat? The interrogator said, Chinese food.
有一次，其中一名审讯人员在试图说服金他们知道她做了什么时感到非常沮丧，他告诉了她。他对她说，我们知道你吃了什么。金回答说，嗯？我吃了什么？审讯人员说，中餐。
We know what you ate.
我们知道你吃了什么。
Huh?
嗯？
We know what you ate!
我们知道你吃了什么！
What? What did I eat?
什么？我吃了什么？
Chinese food!
中餐！
And later on, Kim parroted that back to them. But most of what Jim saw was more subtle than that.
后来，金又把它鹦鹉学舌地还给了他们。但吉姆看到的大部分内容都比那更微妙。
Watching the interrogation, he saw that it had gone down like a long game of 20 Questions. She'd tell him something that didn't fit his theory and he'd say, no, that isn't right. What really happened? And she'd offer something else.
看着审讯过程，他看到它像一场漫长的“20个问题”游戏。她会告诉他一些不符合他理论的东西，他会说，不，那不对。到底发生了什么？她会提供别的东西。
And if that worked, Jim would be really approving, and then that's the detail that he'd write down. And they'd move on until she'd given him a confession that totally fit his pre-existing theory of the crime.
如果那行得通，吉姆会非常赞同，然后那就是他会写下来的细节。他们会继续进行，直到她给了他一个完全符合他预先存在的犯罪理论的告解。
That's how Kim got the name of the drugstore called People's, where the credit card was also used. Jim asked her if she'd been there, and Kim said she didn't remember. He then said, you don't remember? And if you listen, just for an instant, you hear his tone turn disapproving.
金就是这样得到了叫“人民”的药店的名字，信用卡也在那里被使用了。吉姆问她是否去过那里，金说她不记得了。然后他说，你不记得了？如果你听一下，哪怕只是一瞬间，你都会听到他的语气变得不赞成。
Did you go a People's?
你去过人民药店吗？
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
You don't remember?
你不记得了？
Kim picked up on that and changed her answer. She said, oh yeah. Yes, I did. I had to get something.
金听出了那个语气并改变了回答。她说，哦，是的。是的，我去了。我必须买点东西。
Oh yeah. Yes, I did.
哦，是的。是的，我去了。
What'd you buy from--
你买了什么——
I had to get something.
我必须买点东西。
There's only one piece they didn't give Kim. The bit about the shrimp dish. That seems to have been just an extremely unlucky guess.
只有一件东西他们没有给金。关于那道虾类菜肴的部分。那似乎只是一个极其不幸的猜测。
Jim and the other interrogators messed up in other ways, too. In addition to feeding her information, they ignored some really important information she was giving them. There are a few places on the tape where Kim said things that should have raised sudden, immediate doubts as to her guilt.
吉姆和其他审讯人员也在其他方面搞砸了。除了给她喂信息外，他们还忽略了她给他们的非常重要的信息。录像带有几个地方，金说的话本应引发对她有罪的突然、立即的怀疑。
Like this one scene in the video. An interrogator had crime scene pictures of the victim's hands. He let Kim take the photos from him and hold them up to her face. Her reaction wasn't quite what you'd expect from someone who was there. She immediately said, they tied him up!
比如录像里的这一幕。一名审讯人员手里有受害者手的犯罪现场照片。他让金从他那里拿走照片并举到脸前。她的反应并不完全像一个身临其境的人应该有的样子。她立即说，他们捆绑了他！
They tied him. They tied him up!
他们捆绑了他。他们捆绑了他！
They tied him up! Now that's a pretty significant statement. I mean, because she's surprised about the bindings and all of that. But I mean, we never picked up on that, that she was surprised at that.
他们捆绑了他！那是一个非常重要的陈述。我是说，因为她对捆绑之类的东西感到惊讶。但我意思是，我们从来没有察觉到这一点，她对那个感到惊讶。
And later on when she's talking to us about what happened, she talks about how he was tied up with this wire-like thing, about how they didn't take his wedding ring. All things that she could've picked up from the pictures.
后来当她和我们谈论发生的事情时，她谈到了他是如何被那种类似电线的东西捆绑的，谈到了他们没有拿走他的结婚戒指。所有这些都是她可以从照片中收集到的东西。
But the most outrageous thing Jim missed when she told him, I was pregnant. I was seven months pregnant the night of the murder. This was important because the woman they were looking for, who had showed up in the ATM photo and had been seen by liquor store clerks, was clearly not pregnant.
但吉姆错过的一件最离谱的事情是，她说，我怀孕了。谋杀当晚我怀孕七个月了。这很重要，因为他们要寻找的那个出现在ATM照片中，并且被酒类商店职员看到的女人，明显没有怀孕。
I was pregnant. [CRYING] I was seven months pregnant then.
我怀孕了。[哭泣] 那时我怀孕七个月了。
Wait. How did you not hear that?
等等。你是怎么没听到的？
Where that went was right over top of my head. I mean, that was an alibi. And we just didn't pick up on it. Why? Because we weren't looking for it. We were only looking for confirmation of what we thought was true, rather than seeking out what the truth really is.
那东西直接从我头顶飞过去了。我是说，那是一个不在场证明。而我们就是没抓住它。为什么？因为我们没有去寻找它。我们只是在寻找证实我们认为正确的事情，而不是去寻求什么是真正的真相。
There was no record of the pregnancy anywhere in Jim's notes. This was in spite of the fact that when he arrested her, she had been holding a three-week-old baby, meaning she was definitely very pregnant at the time of the murder.
吉姆的笔记里没有任何关于怀孕的记录。尽管事实上当他逮捕她时，她怀里抱着一个三周大的婴儿，这意味着她在谋杀案发生时确实非常显怀。
But no one at the DC police did the math. They didn't feel like they had to. Kim had confessed.
但华盛顿特区的警察里没有人去做这个计算。他们不觉得他们必须这么做。金已经告解了。
Here's what's really troubling. Jim learned all this stuff by accident. At the time, the overwhelming majority of interrogations in this country were not videotaped. Usually, the police only turned on a recorder when they were ready to tape the final confession.
真正令人不安的是这里。吉姆是偶然学到所有这些东西的。当时，这个国家绝大多数的审讯都没有被录像。通常，警察只在准备录制最终告解时才会打开录音机。
But luckily, in Kim's interrogation, Jim and his partners messed up. After they took her confession for credit card fraud, Jim forgot to turn the recorder off. He just kept interviewing her while the video ran, which later gave him a very rare look at the way his interrogation had actually happened.
但幸运的是，在金的审讯中，吉姆和他的伙伴搞砸了。在他们记录了她的信用卡欺诈告解后，吉姆忘了关掉录音机。他只是在录像运行的时候继续审讯她，这后来让他非常罕见地看到了他的审讯实际上是如何发生的。
And by the end of it, Jim saw why Kim's confession had sounded so completely convincing. They had inadvertently rehearsed for almost 17 hours. Kim appeared so cold blooded and unrepentant because she was just exhausted.
到最后，吉姆明白了为什么金的告解听起来如此完全令人信服。他们无意中排练了近17个小时。金看起来如此冷酷、毫无悔意，因为她只是精疲力竭。
If the case hadn't fallen apart and had gone to trial, her final confession is all a jury would have seen, not the interrogation videos from much earlier where she was denying everything and getting help on the facts from the police. Jim is convinced she would have been convicted.
如果案件没有分崩离析并进入审判阶段，她的最终告解是陪审团唯一会看到的东西，而不是更早之前的审讯录像，那时她在否认一切并从警察那里得到事实帮助。吉姆确信她会被定罪。
Once he figured all this out, Jim didn't go around telling everyone he knew that he'd gotten a false confession. At least, not at first.
一旦他弄明白了这一切，吉姆并没有四处告诉他认识的每个人他得到了一个虚假告解。至少，起初没有。
I mean, I'll be honest with you. Who would I have told? My bosses were old school. I mean, they were the dinosaur's dinosaurs. And they would have a problem believing me if I told them that I thought it was a false confession. They would have thought, what's wrong with you? You're crazy.
我是说，我会对你诚实的。我能告诉谁呢？我的老板们是老派的。我是说，他们是恐龙中的恐龙。如果我告诉他们我认为这是一个虚假告解，他们会有麻烦相信我。他们会想，你怎么了？你疯了。
Instead, he quietly pulled up her case file on the police's computer system and typed in that Kim's confession was false.
相反，他悄悄地在警察的电脑系统中调出了她的案卷，并输入了金的告解是虚假的。
If anybody who came behind me-- let's say that I retired, I dropped dead or whatever and somebody came behind me-- I didn't want them bothering Kimberly at all. But later on, her name came up with another detective who came to me and said, look, I pulled up Kim's name in the computer and she was a murder suspect?
如果任何在我之后来的人——假设我退休了，我死了或者别的什么，有人接替我——我不希望他们打扰金伯利。但后来，她的名字出现在另一位侦探那里，他来找我说，看，我在电脑里调出了金的名字，她是一个谋杀嫌疑人？
And I said, oh yeah. But didn't you read the last part? I ruled her out, whatever, and all that.
我说，哦是的。但你没读最后一部分吗？我排除了她，等等，所有这些。
He said yeah, I read that. But she confessed.
他说，是的，我读了。但她告解了。
So I said, listen to what I'm saying. It's a false confession. But it's like it couldn't penetrate.
所以我说，听我说的话。这是一个虚假告解。但就像它无法穿透一样。
For a very long time, it's pretty much been gospel among law enforcement that a confession is a confession is a confession. When Jim went through interrogation training, he was taught that a person would never ever confess to something they didn't do, unless they'd been physically tortured or were mentally ill.
在很长一段时间里，执法部门一直把“告解就是告解就是告解”视为福音。当吉姆接受审讯培训时，他被教导一个人绝对绝对不会为一个他们没做过的事情告解，除非他们受到身体折磨或患有精神疾病。
We've been talking about false confessions for 20 years now, and some people still don't believe in them. There have been cases where suspects falsely confessed, then recanted, backed up their innocence with DNA evidence, and were convicted anyway.
我们讨论虚假告解已经20年了，有些人仍然不相信它们。确实有一些嫌疑人虚假告解，然后推翻，用DNA证据支持他们的清白，却仍然被定罪的案例。
Meanwhile, out in the police world, there's still some resistance to the one thing that most experts agree could help prevent wrongful convictions-- videotaping entire interrogations rather than just confessions. Only 17 states plus the District of Columbia have statutes or court rules on recording police interrogations in cases involving serious crimes.
与此同时，在警察世界里，对于大多数专家一致认为有助于防止错误定罪的一件事——录像整个审讯过程，而不是仅仅录制告解——仍然存在一些阻力。只有17个州加上哥伦比亚特区有关于在涉及严重犯罪的案件中记录警察审讯的法规或法院规则。
When Jim retired from the DC Police in 2010, he'd basically become an evangelist for "I got a false confession and here's how." He started giving presentations about Kim's case to law schools and police conferences, where he pointed out all the ways he'd coached her.
当吉姆在2010年从特区警察局退休时，他基本上成为了“我得到了一个虚假告解，这是如何发生的”的传道者。他开始向法学院和警察会议做关于金案件的演讲，在会上他指出了他引导她的所有方式。
But what's interesting is that when he gives those talks to police, he calls the class something like, "Avoiding Investigative Pitfalls" and then only at the very end slips in a bit about false confession. He said if he led with it, people would walk out.
但有趣的是，当他向警察做那些讲座时，他把课程命名为“避免调查陷阱”，然后只在最后悄悄加入了一点关于虚假告解的内容。他说如果他以那个为开头，人们会走掉。
Though Jim has been talking about Kim's case for years now, to all sorts of audiences, he has no idea whatever happened to her. I found her in another state, far away from Washington, DC.
虽然吉姆多年来一直谈论金的案子，面对各种听众，但他不知道她后来怎么样了。我在另一个州找到了她，离华盛顿特区很远。
The only way she would meet me was in a hotel an hour away from where she lives. She was worried, she said. Kim lives in a small town, and people are nosy. She's spent a long time trying to put the past behind her.
她唯一愿意见我的方式是在离她住处一小时路程的一家酒店。她说她很担心。金住在一个小镇，人们很好奇。她花了很长时间试图把过去抛在身后。
She told me that when Jim first knocked on her door, she thought he had the wrong person. She tried telling him that, but Jim really had no interest in hearing her denials. So I asked her what she was thinking in that interrogation room 19 years ago.
她告诉我，当吉姆第一次敲她的门时，她以为他找错人了。她试着告诉他这一点，但吉姆真的对听她的否认没兴趣。所以我问她19年前在审讯室里在想什么。
First thing that popped in my head was my kids. I just had a newborn. And that's when I started crying. I was starting to get more agitated. It's like, I didn't do this. I don't know what you guys are trying to do.
脑子里冒出的第一件事是我的孩子。我刚有一个新生儿。那时我开始哭。我开始变得更加激动。就像，我没做这个。我不知道你们试图做什么。
I just want to get the process over with. I was tired. I just figured I'd give them something, and maybe they'd just let me go home.
我只是想结束这个过程。我很累。我只是想我会给他们一些东西，也许他们就会让我回家。
I don't know. I was 20 years old. That's what I thought was the best thing for me to do at that time.
我不知道。我20岁。那是那时我认为对我来说最好的做法。
The fact that she felt that way wasn't an accident. Jim said they implied they'd let her see her kids if she talked.
她有那种感觉并不是意外。吉姆说他们暗示如果她开口，就让她见她的孩子。
At one point, I asked Kim if it ever surprised her that she was talked into giving a false confession. She looked at me like I was crazy. She told me she hadn't confessed at all.
有一次，我问金她是否因为被说服做出虚假告解而感到惊讶。她看着我就像看着疯子一样。她告诉我她根本没有告解。
A confession, she explained, means admitting to something you did. But she didn't do anything. Basically, Jim asked her to play a game and she played it.
她解释说，告解意味着承认你所做的事情。但她没做任何事。基本上，吉姆让她玩一个游戏，她就玩了。
It was just something that I just made up by what I saw. I didn't really confess to anything.
那只是我根据我看到的编造出来的东西。我并没有真正告解任何事情。
So I don't totally understand the difference. But it seems like it's an important one and I want to make sure I get it. You're saying you didn't make a confession. You told them something.
所以我不太明白其中的区别。但它似乎是一个重要的区别，我想确保我理解正确。你是说你没有做告解。你告诉了他们一些东西。
I mean, if you put a bunch of pictures in front of a child and you tell them what comes first and what comes next? Nine times out of ten they're going to make up their own thing.
我是说，如果你把一堆图片放在孩子面前，你告诉他们什么先出现，什么后出现？十有八九他们会编造出自己的东西。
I know I wasn't a child. But things were put in front of me, and I just told a story.
我知道我不是孩子。但东西放在我面前，我就讲了一个故事。
Even Kim's court-appointed attorney had wanted her to plead guilty. Some of her family thought she'd done it. So even after she was released from jail, Kim found it impossible to get back on her feet.
甚至金的法庭指定律师也想让她认罪。她的一些家人认为她做了。所以即使在从监狱释放后，金也发现很难重新站起来。
Child Protective Services took her kids. And without her kids, she lost her spot in the family shelter. Without any place to live, she says she was never stable enough to get her kids back. Kim says she spent almost a year and a half on the street, at one point sleeping in a tool shed in a DC Park. She never regained custody of her children.
儿童保护服务带走了她的孩子。没有孩子，她失去了在家庭收容所的位置。没有任何地方住，她说她从未稳定到能接回她的孩子。金说她在街上待了近一年半，有一次睡在华盛顿特区公园的一个工具棚里。她再也没有获得过孩子的监护权。
Kim's case had been dismissed without prejudice, meaning if prosecutors ever found new evidence, they could bring her back in. Kim believes, although I couldn't verify this, that this prevented her from getting jobs, that the charge showed up on background checks, that people judged her for it.
金的案件在没有偏见的情况下被驳回，这意味着如果检察官发现新证据，他们可以把她带回去。金相信，虽然我无法核实这一点，但这阻止了她找到工作，指控出现在背景调查中，人们因此评判她。
Even though I wasn't locked up and I was released, I still felt like I was still in jail, but on the outside world. I mean, I was still treated like I was a criminal. I lost my kids. I was homeless on the street, couldn't get a job.
即使我没有被关起来，我被释放了，但我仍然觉得我好像还在监狱里，但在外部世界。我是说，我仍然被当作罪犯对待。我失去了我的孩子。我无家可归，在街上，找不到工作。
And I really tried my best to turn my life around. I really tried. And soon as they did that background check, it was a no-go. I even tried to join the military, and it came back.
而我真的尽我所能扭转我的生活。我真的试过。一旦他们做了背景调查，这就没戏了。我甚至尝试加入军队，结果也被退回来了。
I'm haunted. I don't know if anything's going to come about. Is this going to be brought back up again? I don't know.
我被困扰着。我不知道会发生什么。这还会被提起来吗？我不知道。
Keep in mind that Kim, by the standards of people who confess falsely, was extremely lucky. She was innocent, and she was released. In her case, in a way, the system worked.
请记住，金，以虚假告解者的标准来看，非常幸运。她是无辜的，她被释放了。在她的案件中，在某种程度上，系统起作用了。
She doesn't feel lucky, though. She feels like her life has been ruined. While Jim has spent most of the last decade using Kim's story as a cautionary tale, Kim herself had no idea until I talked to her that he'd ever thought about it again, let alone that he thought she was innocent, or that he blamed himself. So when she found out about this, she stood up and walked slowly out of the room, sobbing.
不过她并不觉得自己幸运。她觉得她的生活被毁了。当吉姆在过去十年里大部分时间都在利用金的故事作为警示故事时，金本人在和我谈话之前根本不知道他还会再次想到它，更不用说他认为她是无辜的，或者他自责。所以当她发现这件事时，她站起来慢慢走出房间，啜泣着。
He could have really, if he really wanted to, make things right. He knows how to. He's a former detective, or whatever he is now. I don't know. He knows how to get a hold of me, and that's the thing that bugs me the most. [SOBBING]
如果他真的想，他本可以真正地纠正错误。他知道怎么做。他是一位前侦探，或者他现在是什么。我不知道。他知道怎么联系我，这就是最让我烦恼的事情。[啜泣]
I can't change my past. I don't have any of my kids because of it. It's still on my record.
我无法改变我的过去。我因为这个失去了所有的孩子。它仍然在我的记录上。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
你好？
Kim? This is Jim Trainum.
金？我是吉姆·特雷纳姆。
When I interviewed Kim, she surprised me by asking for Jim's contact information. A week later, they ended up connecting by phone. They let me record.
当我采访金时，她问我要吉姆的联系方式，这让我很惊讶。一周后，他们最终通过电话联系上了。他们让我录音。
I just want to first open by saying that I am very sorry for what you had gone through back then and all the pain that it caused you and problems that it's caused you.
我首先想开场说，我非常抱歉你当时经历的一切，以及它给你带来的所有痛苦和问题。
In the years since he figured out his mistake, Jim had often thought about contacting Kim. But at the end, he decided not to. He consulted with psychologists who cautioned him about the impacts on Kim if he reached out to her. Plus, he told me, he was also a little scared.
在他发现错误的这些年里，吉姆经常想到联系金。但最后，他决定不这样做。他咨询了心理学家，他们提醒他如果他接触金会对她产生什么影响。另外，他告诉我，他也有点害怕。
As you might expect, it was sort of an awkward conversation. Jim sounded really nervous. And for the first hour, he sounded like he was giving one of his academic speeches on how investigations go wrong. He used a lot of terms like "verification bias" and "contamination" to try and explain how false confessions happen, how he and his officers had messed up. He went on and on like this.
如你所料，那是一个有点尴尬的对话。吉姆听起来真的很紧张。在第一个小时里，他听起来就像在做关于调查如何出错的学术演讲。他用了许多诸如“验证偏见”和“污染”之类的术语，试图解释虚假告解是如何发生的，他和他的警官们是如何搞砸的。他就这样一直说下去。
Through it all, it sounded like he wanted her to understand that they had meant well. They had tried their best, it just hadn't been good enough. To me, it sounded like he was saying, it's my mistake, but it wasn't completely my fault. Kim listened patiently, but after a while she cut in.
自始至终，听起来他想让她明白他们是出于好意。他们尽了最大的努力，只是不够好。对我来说，听起来他是在说，这是我的错误，但不是完全我的错。金耐心地听着，但过了一会儿她插话了。
I'm not trying to seem like I'm being rude or anything. But you've got to understand after 20 years, 19 years, whatever years it is, you explaining the case to me, for what?
我不想让自己看起来很粗鲁或什么。但你必须明白，20年后，19年后，不管多少年过去了，你向我解释这个案子，为了什么？
I'm not expecting you to forgive me, OK?
我没指望你原谅我，好吗？
You were doing your job. If you knew all this, why didn't you try to find me?
你在做你的工作。如果你知道所有这些，为什么你不试着找到我？
I mean, I'll be honest with you. It may have been the wrong decision. All I can do is do what I can from this point on.
我是说，我会对你诚实的。这可能是一个错误的决定。我现在能做的就是从这一点开始做我能做的。
Kim didn't care about his hand wringing. She'd been there. She knew how it happened. She just wanted Jim to help her get her record expunged.
金不在乎他的苦恼。她身临其境。她知道它是如何发生的。她只是想让吉姆帮她把记录删掉。
Well, I do want this record thing taken care of.
好吧，我确实想把这个记录的事处理掉。
OK.
好的。
And I can't do it without any help.
没有帮助我做不到。
I have a contact. I have a person in the public defender's office who does that sort of thing. I will work with him. And I will provide him with an affidavit, explain in the affidavit how you are innocent.
我有一个联系人。我在公设辩护人办公室有一个人做那种事。我会和他合作。我会给他提供一份宣誓书，在宣誓书中解释你是如何无辜的。
I can tell in a way that you're sincere. But it's going to take me time to start trusting.
我能看出某种程度上你是真诚的。但这需要时间让我开始信任。
Jim also offered to help Kim find counseling, to help put her in touch with other people who had given false confessions, or who study them. And that's when the conversation started to change. 19 years ago, he'd tried to convince her she was guilty. Now he was trying to convince her it wasn't her fault.
吉姆还提议帮助金找到咨询，帮助她与做出虚假告解或研究它们的其他人取得联系。那就是对话开始改变的时候。19年前，他试图说服她她有罪。现在他试图说服她这不是她的错。
I mean, so many people ask me, but why did you even say that you did it? So it kind of comes back on me as like I'm the stupid one.
我是说，很多人问我，但你为什么甚至说你做了它？所以这有点回到我身上，好像我是那个笨蛋。
No. No, you're not the stupid one. You were manipulated. I mean, you were doing what, at that time, you thought was best.
不。不，你不是那个笨蛋。你被操纵了。我是说，你当时做的是你认为最好的。
None of this, none of this, is on you. Not one thing. I mean, people may try to say, well, I would never have said that! Well, you  know what? Yes, you would've. In the right circumstance, you would have. I promise you that.
这一切，这一切，都不是你的错。一件都没有。我是说，人们可能会试着说，好吧，我绝不会那样说！好吧，你知道吗？是的，你会的。在那种情况下，你也会。我向你保证。
Yeah, I guess it just takes a little bit for it to all soak in for me not to feel the way I feel.
是的，我想这只是需要一点时间让它全部渗透，让我不再有现在的感觉。
I listened to them talk without breaking in. Years ago, in an interrogation room, each of them did something they never would've thought they'd do. And now here they were again, their situations reversed. Jim was confessing to her.
我听着他们谈话而没有打断。多年前，在审讯室里，他们每个人都做了他们认为自己绝不会做的事情。而现在他们又在这里，他们的处境互换了。吉姆在向她告解。
Saul Elbein lives in Austin, Texas.
索尔·埃尔本住在得克萨斯州奥斯汀。
[MUSIC - "VIDEOTAPE" BY RADIOHEAD]
[音乐 - 电台司令的《录像带》]
Coming up, talking to the police may mess up your life, even if you're innocent. But what happens when you try not to talking to them? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，和警察谈话可能会搞砸你的生活，即使你是无辜的。但当你尝试不和他们谈话时会发生什么？那将在几分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Confessions."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择某个主题，带给你关于那个主题的各种故事。今天的节目，“告解”。
So in Act One of today's show, you heard about a person who's wrongly accused of murder who gives a false confession. This next story is about a person who is also wrongly accused of murder, only in this case, they do not confess.
所以在今天节目的第一幕，你听到了一个被诬告谋杀的人做出了虚假告解。下一个故事是关于一个同样被诬告谋杀的人，只是在这种情况下，他们没有告解。
This is Act Two. Act Two, "You Don't Say."
这是第二幕。第二幕，“你别说”。
The murder in this act is a particularly horrible one. In Nashville in 1975, a nine-year-old girl named Marcia Trimble went out to deliver some Girl Scout cookies, and she did not come home. She was found dead a month later-- strangled, sexually assaulted.
这一幕中的谋杀案是一起特别可怕的案件。1975年在纳什维尔，一个叫玛西娅·特林布尔的九岁女孩出去送女童军饼干，她没有回家。一个月后她被发现死亡——被勒死，遭受性侵。
Nashville at the time had not seen many crimes like this. It shook the whole city. Volunteer groups and Boy Scout troops searched for her. It was one of those crimes that made people rethink how safe their city was.
那时的纳什维尔还没见过多少这样的罪行。它震惊了整个城市。志愿者团体和童子军部队搜索了她。这是那种让人重新思考他们的城市有多安全的罪行之一。
The case went unsolved for decades. And then in 2009, thanks to a DNA match, a convicted rapist named Jerome Barrett was found guilty in Marcia's death. But all that time, more than 30 years, law enforcement officials suspected that a different guy had committed the crime. That person was Jeffrey Womack.
案件几十年来未破。然后在2009年，由于DNA比对，一个叫杰罗姆·巴雷特的被定罪的强奸犯在玛西娅的死亡案件中被判有罪。但所有那些时间，超过30年，执法官员怀疑是另一个家伙犯下的罪行。那个人就是杰弗里·沃马克。
Jeffrey Womack was 15 when he became a suspect in Marcia Trimble's murder. He was 49 when Jerome Barrett was convicted.
杰弗里·沃马克成为玛西娅·特林布尔谋杀案的嫌疑人时才15岁。当杰罗姆·巴雷特被定罪时，他已经49岁了。
Womack didn't speak publicly about the ordeal for years, until last year, when he and his attorney co-wrote a memoir and appeared in a documentary about the case. Before that, as producer Lisa Pollak explains, Jeffrey Womack was known, for better or for worse, not for what he did say, but for what he wouldn't say.
沃马克多年来没有公开谈论过这次磨难，直到去年，当他和他的律师合写了一本回忆录并出现在一部关于该案的纪录片中时。在此之前，正如制片人丽莎·波拉克解释的那样，杰弗里·沃马克之所以闻名，无论好坏，不是因为他说了什么，而是因为他拒绝说什么。
I don't think I fully understood what it meant to be Jeffrey Womack, to be a suspect in a murder you didn't commit, until I talked to a woman named Demetria Kalodimos. She's a TV news anchor and investigative reporter in Nashville. Demetria told me that in 1984, when she first moved to Nashville, she went to a restaurant with her coworkers, and one of her colleagues spotted Jeffrey Womack in the kitchen.
在我和一个叫德米特里亚·卡洛迪莫斯的女人交谈之前，我不认为我完全理解成为杰弗里·沃马克是什么意思，成为你没有犯下的谋杀案的嫌疑人。她是纳什维尔的一位电视新闻主播和调查记者。德米特里亚告诉我，在1984年，当她第一次搬到纳什维尔时，她和同事去了一家餐厅，她的一个同事在厨房里发现了杰弗里·沃马克。
Someone whispered over to me and said, see that guy over there cooking? He killed a nine-year-old girl.
有人悄悄对我说，看到那边做饭的那个家伙了吗？他杀了一个九岁的小女孩。
And I looked and I thought, wow, what's he doing cooking? Why is he here? And they said, well, it's a long story. They just couldn't get him, but they will.
我看了看，我想，哇，他在做什么饭？他为什么在这里？他们说，好吧，这说来话长。他们只是没能抓住他，但他们会抓住的。
At this point, in 1984, it had been four years since the murder charges against him had been dropped for lack of evidence. And two years since the district attorney who'd issued those charges told the newspaper that he no longer believed Jeffrey had anything to do with the crime. And yet, people still believed that Jeffrey Womack had gotten away with murder.
此时，在1984年，距离撤销对他的谋杀指控已经四年了。距离发布这些指控的地区检察官告诉报纸他不再相信杰弗里与该罪行有任何关系已经两年了。然而，人们仍然相信杰弗里·沃马克逍遥法外了。
Jeffrey wasn't the only suspect in Marcia Trimble's murder, but the cops had had their eyes on him from the night she went missing. They believed that the person who killed her was a young white male, probably a teenager from Marcia's neighborhood, a quiet, middle-class area called Green Hills.
杰弗里不是玛西娅·特林布尔谋杀案中唯一的嫌疑人，但警察从她失踪的那晚起就一直盯着他。他们相信杀死她的人是一个年轻白人男性，可能是来自玛西娅社区的一个十几岁男孩，一个叫绿山的安静、中产阶级区域。
Jeffrey was all of those things. He was 15. He and Marcia lived on the same street. And on the day she disappeared, Jeffrey was one of the last people to see her. She'd come to his house collecting money for Girl Scout cookies. He told her he didn't have money to pay her, but that he'd bring it by in a while.
杰弗里具备所有这些特质。他15岁。他和玛西娅住在同一条街上。在她失踪的那天，杰弗里是最后见到她的人之一。她来到他家收女童军饼干的钱。他告诉她他没钱付给她，但他过一会儿会送过去。
Later that night, when he heard Marcia was missing, he went to her house to tell the cops that he'd seen her. He figured it would be a quick conversation. But the way he remembers it, three cops took a look at him, his long hair, his smart alecky attitude, and the shoes in which he'd written [BLEEP] you in ballpoint pen, and started interrogating him right there in the house about where he'd been that day, asking him to account for his time in five-minute increments.
那天晚上晚些时候，当他听说玛西娅失踪时，他去她家告诉警察他见过她。他以为那会是一次简短的谈话。但据他记得，三个警察看了他一眼，他那头长发，他那种自以为是的态度，以及他用圆珠笔写着“[哔]你”的鞋子，就开始在房子里审讯他，问他那天去过哪里，要求他以五分钟为增量说明他的时间。
They were very aggressive.
他们非常激进。
This is Jeffrey.
这是杰弗里。
I just know that when it was over, I was so confused about why all these questions like this? They'd ask them one way and they'd ask them another way. And I couldn't ever get the answer right.
我只知道当它结束时，我很困惑为什么会有所有这些问题？他们以一种方式问，他们又以另一种方式问。而且我从来没能得到正确的答案。
I should tell you that police deny they grilled Jeffrey. One of the three detectives, Tommy Jacobs, told me they only questioned him for 15 minutes, and that it wasn't contentious.
我应该告诉你警察否认他们审问了杰弗里。其中一名探员，汤米·雅各布斯，告诉我他们只盘问了他15分钟，而且并不激烈。
Then they asked me to take off my coat, told me to empty my pockets.
然后他们让我脱掉外套，告诉我清空我的口袋。
And at the point when they had him empty his pockets--
而在他们让他清空口袋的那一点——
Again, Demetria Kalodimos. Last year she made a documentary about the Trimble case.
再次是德米特里亚·卡洛迪莫斯。去年她制作了一部关于特林布尔案的纪录片。
That visual never left the heart of this case.
那个视觉画面从未离开过这个案件的核心。
I had half rolls of pennies in my pocket and a five-dollar bill.
我口袋里有半卷便士和一张五美元钞票。
Remember, he told the cops that he didn't have money to pay for Girl Scout cookies. And now here he was with money.
记住，他告诉警察他没钱付女童军饼干。而现在他在这里有了钱。
And I had a condom.
而且我有一个避孕套。
The clincher. He's got a condom. And what's a 15-year-old doing with a condom? And a little girl's missing, and that just sounds too unsavory.
定论。他有一个避孕套。一个15岁的人拿着避孕套在做什么？而且一个小女孩失踪了，那听起来太令人反感了。
The real reason why Jeffrey had a condom might also sound unsavory. Unbeknownst to his parents, he was sleeping with one of the moms in the neighborhood. What happened next, at least how Jeffrey tells it, is that his mom got word that her son was being interrogated in a bedroom at the Trimbles' house, and she and their next-door neighbor, Peggy, headed over there to put an end to it.
杰弗里手里拿着避孕套的真正原因可能听起来也很反感。在父母不知情的情况下，他正在与附近的一位妈妈发生性关系。接下来发生的事情，至少是杰弗里讲述的方式，是他的妈妈听说她的儿子正在特林布尔家的卧室里接受审讯，她和他们的隔壁邻居佩吉一起赶过去结束它。
Peggy just pushed the door open and just made a statement, if you want to talk to him, you can talk to his lawyer.
佩吉只是推开门并声明，如果你想和他谈，你可以和他的律师谈。
And that's really when things changed. Just the mention of having a lawyer automatically put even more suspicion over Jeffrey. The thinking was, no one's accused him of anything. Why does he need an attorney?
而那才是事情真正改变的时候。仅仅提到拥有律师就自动让杰弗里受到了更多的怀疑。当时的逻辑是，没有人指控他任何事情。他为什么需要律师？
The next day, Jeffrey found himself face to face with John Hollins, a well-known attorney in Nashville. He'd represented Peggy in her divorce.
第二天，杰弗里发现自己面对的是约翰·霍林斯，纳什维尔一位著名的律师。他曾代表佩吉处理离婚案。
He asked me to tell him, tell me exactly what happened yesterday. And I told him. And I told him what happened at the Trimble house.
他让我告诉他，告诉我昨天到底发生了什么。我告诉了他。我告诉了他特林布尔家发生的事情。
And then he gave Jeffrey an instruction that would come to define both the case and his life.
然后他给了杰弗里一个将定义该案件和他生活的指示。
He said, do not talk to these people anymore. Do not talk to any more detectives. Tell them talk to me.
他说，不要再和这些人说话了。不要再和任何侦探说话。告诉他们和我说话。
So Jeffrey didn't talk. And since he wasn't talking, police tried other ways to get information out of him. When he was 17, working in a restaurant, an undercover cop joined the staff as a dishwasher, hung out with Jeffrey, went drinking with him to see if he'd say anything about the Trimble case.
所以杰弗里没有说话。由于他不说话，警察尝试其他方法从他那里获取信息。当他17岁时，在一家餐厅工作，一名卧底警察作为洗碗工加入员工行列，和杰弗里混在一起，和他一起去喝酒，看看他是否会说出关于特林布尔案的任何事情。
Another coworker wore a wire and asked Jeffrey point blank if he killed Marcia. He said no. Once, on the anniversary of her death, they staked out the cemetery in case Jeffery went to Marcia's grave. He didn't.
另一位同事戴着窃听器，直截了当地问杰弗里是否杀了玛西娅。他说没有。有一次，在她去世的周年纪念日，他们监视了墓地，以防杰弗里去玛西娅的墓地。他没去。
Finally, four a half years after the murder, investigators had enough evidence-- evidence that later fell apart-- to arrest Jeffrey. They brought him in in the middle of the night.
最终，在谋杀案发生四年半后，调查人员有了足够的证据——后来分崩离析的证据——逮捕杰弗里。他们在半夜把他带走。
When I talked to the arresting officer, she was adamant that no one pressured Jeffrey to talk or even asked him for a statement. But Jeffrey says they did, that one officer taunted him about how he supposedly strangled Marcia, how he grabbed her by the throat and wouldn't let go. And then he was given an ultimatum.
当我与逮捕警官交谈时，她坚持认为没有人施压让杰弗里说话，甚至没有要求他做声明。但杰弗里说他们做了，一名警官嘲弄他，说他如何设想勒死了玛西娅，如何抓住她的喉咙并不放手。然后他被下了最后通牒。
This is your last chance to talk to us. If you want to talk to us, you better talk to us now. I said, OK, I'll talk to you.
这是你和我们谈话的最后机会。如果你想和我们谈话，你最好现在和我们谈话。我说，好吧，我和你们谈。
And she grabbed her pen and pad. As a matter of fact, there was a couple other officers in there. I can't remember. And I just looked at them and said, [BLEEP] you.
她抓起她的笔和记事本。事实上，还有几个警察也在里面。我记不清了。我只是看着他们说，[哔]你。
For years, Jeffrey says, the question followed him. If he was innocent, why wouldn't he just talk to police?
多年来，杰弗里说，问题一直困扰着他。如果他是无辜的，他为什么不和警察谈谈？
A lot of people were friends of my parents that wanted me to go down and talk to the district attorney. Wanted me to go talk to the police department, straighten all this out, make it end. This is killing your parents.
很多人是我父母的朋友，想让我下去和地区检察官谈谈。想让我去警察局谈谈，理清这一切，让它结束。这正在害死你的父母。
But that wasn't the thing to do. My best friend, Doug Green-- all you need to do is sit down and talk to these people. No!
但那不是该做的事。我最好的朋友，道格·格林——你所要做的就是坐下来和这些人谈谈。不！
Well, your best friend told you to talk to the cops?
好吧，你最好的朋友让你和警察谈谈？
Yeah. He wanted me to sit down and talk to them. He thought I could sit down and talk to them and straighten it all out. They wanted me to sit down and talk to them and confess to it.
是的。他想让我坐下来和他们谈谈。他认为我可以坐下来和他们谈谈并理清这一切。他们想让我坐下来和他们谈谈并认罪。
There was two different things. They didn't want to hear from me that I had nothing to do with it. That's not what they wanted to hear. So I really had nothing to say to them. It was useless for me to speak to them.
那是两码事。他们不想从我这里听到我与此事无关。那不是他们想听的。所以我真的没什么话对他们说。对我来说，和他们说话是徒劳的。
It didn't help Jeffrey's reputation that he kept his mouth shut while the cops talked to reporters. But even when he was given permission to tell his side, Jeffrey didn't take it.
当警察和记者谈话时，他保持沉默，这对杰弗里的声誉没有帮助。但即使在他被允许说出他的立场时，杰弗里也没有这么做。
Today, for the first time, Jeffrey Womack talked publicly about the Trimble murder investigation and his part in it.
今天，杰弗里·沃马克首次公开谈论特林布尔谋杀案调查以及他在其中的角色。
This is an interview from right after the murder charges against Jeffrey were dropped. The perfect time, you might think, to proclaim himself an innocent victim.
这是一次在针对杰弗里的谋杀指控被撤销后不久的采访。你可能认为这是他宣布自己是无辜受害者的最佳时机。
By his choice, Womack did not elaborate on most of the questions, deferring to the lawyers in some cases.
按他的选择，沃马克没有详述大多数问题，在某些情况下推脱给律师。
Anything you would like to say that you've been wanting to get off your back for these many years now that rumors have been flying and stories have going about your situation?
现在谣言满天飞，关于你的处境的故事不断，有什么你想说的话，你想把它从你的背上卸下来吗？
No.
不。
Nothing at all?
一点都没有？
Alan Griggs, Channel Four News.
艾伦·格里格斯，第四频道新闻。
We'd heard a lot about him, but we never heard a lot from him.
我们听到了很多关于他的传闻，但我们从未听过他自己说很多话。
Again, Demetria Kalodimos.
再次是德米特里亚·卡洛迪莫斯。
Do you think the silence made him look guiltier to people?
你认为沉默让他在人们看来更像是有罪的吗？
People will tell you that. Well, this guy's obviously guilty. I mean, look at him. He doesn't say a word. He looks straight ahead. He doesn't seem to show any emotion.
人们会告诉你那点。好吧，这家伙显然有罪。我是说，看看他。他一句话也不说。他直视前方。他似乎没有表现出任何情绪。
And I think that was a feeling of a lot of reporters covering the case, and it was the feeling certainly of the audience we were presenting it to. I've always thought if it were me, I'd be yelling from the rooftops. I wouldn't be listening to my lawyer and staying behind closed doors and never saying another word.
我认为那是许多报道此案的记者的感觉，而且这肯定是我们将它呈现给的观众的感觉。我一直认为如果是我，我会从屋顶上大喊大叫。我不会听我的律师的话，呆在闭门造车，再也不说一句话。
When I asked Jeffrey's attorney, John Hollins, if he worried that the silence hurt Jeffrey, made him seem unsympathetic to people, he said, I wasn't worried about him being sympathetic. I was worried about them trying to put him in the penitentiary.
当我问杰弗里的律师约翰·霍林斯，他是否担心沉默伤害了杰弗里，让他看起来不值得同情时，他说，我不担心他是否值得同情。我担心的是他们试图把他送进监狱。
It probably won't surprise you that both the detectives I talked to said they weren't out to get Jeffrey, that they were following leads, trying to eliminate suspects or build a case, if there was one to build. They said if Jeffrey had talked to them, maybe they could have cleared him.
我不担心那会让你吃惊，我和他们交谈的两名侦探都说他们并不是要针对杰弗里，他们是在跟踪线索，试图排除嫌疑人或建立案件，如果有案件可建的话。他们说如果杰弗里和他们谈过，也许他们就能洗清他的嫌疑。
But Jeffrey and his lawyer both believe that not talking is what kept him free. For Jeffrey, not talking had other consequences. There were people who gave him the cold shoulder or talked behind his back once they learned he was that Jeffrey Womack. He told me a story about a woman he once liked, somebody who used to come drink at the restaurant where he worked.
但杰弗里和他的律师都认为不说话是他保持自由的原因。对杰弗里来说，不说话还有其他后果。有些人因为他知道他是那个杰弗里·沃马克后，对他冷眼相待或在背后议论他。他告诉我一个他曾经喜欢的女人的故事，一个曾经来餐厅喝酒的女人。
And we just started hanging out with each other. And she freaked out when she found out who I was. I just can't hang around with you anymore, because of who you are.
然后我们刚开始和对方闲逛。当她发现我是谁时，她吓坏了。我不能再和你闲逛了，因为你是谁。
Well, how did you feel when she said that to you?
好吧，当她对你这么说时，你感觉如何？
I felt bad. Because I couldn't explain how to get out of it, how to make it where, don't worry about it. It's OK. How can I defend myself for something I didn't do?
我感觉很糟糕。因为我无法解释如何摆脱它，如何让它变得，别担心它。没关系。我怎么能为我没有做过的事情辩护？
You said there is no defense. But there is a defense. You didn't want to say, I didn't do it. I'm the one who's being wronged here. Why not defend yourself at all to people and make your case? You had a case to make.
你说没有辩护。但有一个辩护。你不想说，我没做。我是那个被冤枉的人。为什么不向人们为自己辩护并提出你的案件？你有一个案件要提。
What you're saying sounds good. But when you sit down and you start talking to someone about this, it's, well, how did you get in this mess? Even when I would say I had nothing to do with it, well, you must have done something because they wouldn't keep coming after if you didn't do anything wrong. The police department doesn't do that.
你说的听起来不错。但当你坐下来开始和某人谈论这件事时，就是，好吧，你卷入这个混乱是怎么回事？即使当我说我与它无关时，好吧，你一定做了什么，因为如果他们没有做错任何事，他们就不会继续追你。警察局不会那样做。
Well, they did do that. The horrible fact of the whole thing was that they did. So you learn to shut up about it. You learn to stop.
好吧，他们确实那样做了。整件事可怕的事实是他们确实这样做了。所以你学会了闭嘴。你学会了停止。
Jeffrey is 54 now. He doesn't think the Trimble case ruined his life. And when people suggest it has, he doesn't like it. He doesn't want to play the victim, and he doesn't want people psychoanalyzing him. Listen to how he reacted when Demetria, during one of our interviews, brought up the V word.
杰弗里现在54岁了。他不认为特林布尔案毁了他的生活。当人们建议它毁了时，他不喜欢。他不想扮演受害者，他不想人们分析他。听听当德米特里亚在我们采访中提到V词（受害者）时，他是如何反应的。
Do you think of yourself as a victim sometimes?
你有时候会认为自己是受害者吗？
I don't know. I really don't know.
我不知道。我真的不知道。
I do. Just think about what your life would have been if you even--
我是。想想如果你哪怕——你的生活会是什么样
That's Kathy, an old friend of Jeffrey's in the background. She saying, just think of what your life would have been.
那是凯西，杰弗里在后台的一位老朋友。她在说，想想你的生活会是什么样。
Don't know. Don't know what my life would have been. I just don't know. Because what do you think your life would have been? Who knows?
不知道。不知道我的生活会是什么样。我只是不知道。因为你认为你的生活会是什么样？谁知道呢？
Jeffrey's had his share of hard stuff in his life. He went through a divorce. He was a heavy drinker. He's been to rehab. But he won't blame the murder case for any of that.
杰弗里在他生活中经历了不少困难。他经历过离婚。他曾是个酗酒者。他去过康复中心。但他不会把那些归咎于谋杀案。
In the past 30 years, Jeffrey says, there were times he'd go months without even thinking about the Trimble case. And then, inevitably, there'd be a news story about it, the mystery that had never been solved. And the same old questions would come up again. And sometimes even his own mother wasn't sure what to think.
在过去的30年里，杰弗里说，有时他会几个月都不去想特林布尔案。然后，不可避免地，会有一个关于它的新闻报道，从未解决的谜团。同样的老问题又会出现。有时甚至连他自己的母亲都不确定该怎么想。
She'd be very upset, and she'd be crying. And it's hard to explain to your mother that you had nothing to do with this after they repeatedly, for 20-something years, kept saying Jeffrey Womack's got something to hide. Jeffrey Womack knows something. Jeffrey Womack's still a subject.
她会非常心烦，她会哭。而当你告诉你的母亲你与此无关后，他们一再地，在20多年里，一直说杰弗里·沃马克有什么隐瞒。杰弗里·沃马克知道什么。杰弗里·沃马克仍然是一个主题。
And then she would say, do you know anything about this? No. You sure? You don't know anything about this?
然后她会说，你对此知道什么吗？不。你确定？你对此什么都不知道？
It was hard. That was the hardest part. I could handle what anybody else would say. It was heartbreaking that telling her once I didn't have anything to do with it wasn't enough.
那很难。那是最难的部分。我可以处理任何人会说的任何话。心碎的是，告诉她一次我与此无关是不够的。
It wasn't until 2009, when another man was tried and convicted for killing Marcia, that Jeffrey was fully and undeniably cleared. The case was solved when detectives discovered that the DNA on Marcia Trimble's shirt matched the DNA of a convicted rapist named Jerome Barrett.
直到2009年，当另一个人因为杀害玛西娅受审并被定罪时，杰弗里才被完全且无可辩驳地洗清罪名。案件解决时，侦探发现玛西娅·特林布尔衬衫上的DNA与一个叫杰罗姆·巴雷特的被定罪强奸犯的DNA匹配。
Even though Barrett had been arrested for other sexual assaults near Trimble's neighborhood near the time of her death, and was charged with murdering a student the same month she disappeared, the Nashville police had never considered Barrett a suspect. Remember, they'd been looking for a white teenage boy from the neighborhood. And Jerome Barrett was black, an adult, and lived nowhere near the Trimbles. But even a DNA match was not enough to convince everybody in Nashville that Jeffrey's innocent. Again, Demetria Kalodimos.
即使巴雷特在玛西娅死亡时间附近在特林布尔社区附近因其他性侵犯被捕，并被指控谋杀了一名学生在同一月份她失踪，纳什维尔警察从未考虑巴雷特为嫌疑人。记住，他们一直在寻找一个来自社区的十几岁白人男孩。杰罗姆·巴雷特是黑人，成年人，住在离特林布尔家很远的地方。但即使是DNA比对也不足以让纳什维尔的所有人都相信杰弗里是无辜的。再次是德米特里亚·卡洛迪莫斯。
At the time when we were putting the documentary together, I thought that everyone would be convinced. And I was frankly amazed at some of the comments that I still got from people saying, yeah, but he worked with Jerome Barrett, and they probably knew each other. And I mean, there are still people who will not let this go.
当时我们组装纪录片时，我以为每个人都会相信。而我坦率地对人们仍然给我的评论感到惊讶，他们说，是的，但他和杰罗姆·巴雷特一起工作，他们可能认识彼此。我的意思是，仍然有不会放过这件事的人。
Demetria says the cops she's interviewed haven't expressed much sympathy for Jeffrey.
德米特里亚说，她采访过的警察没有对杰弗里表示太多同情。
Every single one of them said he asked for what he got. Everything he got was his fault. If he had just talked to us, if he had just did this, if he had just done that. There's never been any sort of apology.
他们中的每一个都说他自找的。他得到的一切都是他的错。如果他早点和我们谈，如果他早点做了这个，如果他早点做了那个。从来没有过任何形式的道歉。
Jeffrey's not holding out hope for an apology, and he probably shouldn't. In July, the weekly Nashville Scene published its annual "You Are So Nashville If" issue, and one of the items on the list was, you are so Nashville if you still haven't apologized to Jeffrey Womack.
杰弗里不指望道歉，他可能也不应该指望。七月，周刊《纳什维尔场景》出版了其年度“如果你是如此纳什维尔”版，清单上的项目之一是，如果你仍然没有向杰弗里·沃马克道歉，那么你是如此纳什维尔。
Lisa Pollak is one of the producers of our show. Jeffrey Womack and his attorney have told their story in a book called The Suspect , A Memoir . Their ghost writer, who's a Nashville journalist named E. Thomas Wood, got unprecedented access to the Marcia Trimble police file during his reporting, and we drew on his research for our story. Our thanks to him.
丽莎·波拉克是我们节目的制片人之一。杰弗里·沃马克和他的律师在书《嫌疑人，回忆录》中讲述了他们的故事。他们的代笔者，一位叫E.托马斯·伍德的纳什维尔记者，在报道期间获得了对玛西娅·特林布尔警局档案的前所未有的访问权限，我们从他的研究中获得了我们故事的素材。感谢他。
Demetria Kalodimos's documentary on the Trimble case is called Indelible , The Case Against Jeffrey Womack. There's a link to it on our website.
德米特里亚·卡洛迪莫斯关于特林布尔案的纪录片叫《不可磨灭，针对杰弗里·沃马克的案件》。我们的网站上有它的链接。
[MUSIC - "SUSPECT," BY THE GENERATORS]
[音乐 - 发电机队的“嫌疑人”]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from Dana Chivvis.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩制作，与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔洪、萨拉·科尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克合作。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。达娜·奇维斯提供了制作帮助。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant.
塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。
Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damian Gray and from Rob Geddis.
阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨运行我们的网站。米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔提供了研究帮助。达米安·格雷和罗布·格迪斯提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
Thanks, as always, to our show's co-founder, Torey Malatia. Little known fact about Torey, Sudoku master. And don't try to make fun of him for it.
感谢，像往常一样，我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。关于托里的鲜为人知的事实，数独大师。别试着为此嘲笑他。
Right. It's called a skill. There's a lot of people who lots of money with that ability.
对。这叫技巧。有很多人靠那种能力赚了很多钱。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。